foreign
[Music]
there's a lot going on but Today's Show
is brought to you by Pluto TV which
offers hundreds of free live channels
and thousands of free on-demand movies
thank you to Pluto TV
um there's so much to get into folks
we're dressed like game show hosts
guests in the chat which game show host
each of us is
um we're gonna cover a lot of Black Adam
stuff we're going to cover some wakanda
forever stuff and we will be doing the
hot ones challenge
okay we got 10 nasty freaky hot sauces
lined up along the front of this table
more on that in a moment it will be
based on Super Chat redemptions so if
you feel like punishing all of us
equally throw us a couple of doubloons
in the chat oh no uh but coming up today
uh yes black Black Adam updates no
spoilers we're gonna be very careful not
to spoil it there already is an ending
explained on our Channel if you feel
like being spoiled uh Eric Voss has
already done that work for us
um knew a kind of forever teaser that is
thought provoking we've got a big
question we're going to try to answer
um also uh per our game show host
outfits we will be playing a little
Family Feud care of Steve Harvey
Clements over there
no I'm I'm Steve Harvey the white Steve
Harvey
nah I'm Dr Phil and I gotta say if
you're looking to take control of your
life you need to come on my show so I
can [ __ ] it up way worse then you can
sue me and then professionals can get
involved and then actually help I was
telling we had to be game shows
I'll play The Most Dangerous Game oh
messing with people's mental health
taking people who have a little problem
making that problem freaking huge
legal system unpacking what's going on
and all the damage that I've done the
prize
I don't know your heart beating every
day is surprising thank you don't forget
to watch Bowl on TV yes
based on my life okay we've also got uh
Brandon Barrick is here as the uh uh I'm
Kirk Fogg from Legends of the Hidden
Temple and if you can find Genghis
Khan's Los porno tablets in time you'll
get one half of the temple coin which
will save you from a temple God oh wow
and uh the tribe is spoken I'm Jeff
Probst uh someone guessed it in the chat
yeah
oh nice
um okay yes so we're doing the hot ones
challenge we will in the middle point of
the episode and at the end of the
episode we will hit all of the hot
sauces that have been redeemed up into
that point the first three are going to
be a 50 increments so 150 bucks makes us
take three different hot sauce after
that it's a hundred dollar increments so
uh and really when you get into beyond
the halfway point is just pure pain
that's where you start seeing the
savings though that's where you see your
money go first
I want my balls to be on fire by the end
of this it's really nice hey read my
lips my balls must be a flame I know at
the end of this show okay and nobody can
see your lips does Dr Phil say read my
lips you know that George hwa also dummy
let it be known Tommy has a mustache on
top of a mustache yeah there's no better
metaphor for this show it's a mustache
on a Mustang hey don't piss on my face
and tell me it's a rainstorm okay you
can teach a dog to sit on the porch but
you can't make a squirrel do geometry
let's get into these headlines yeah yeah
let's get into these headlines
[Music]
on some quick DC news I'm gonna not do
that voice
before we get into things Black Adam
opened today you guys uh our ending
explain is out like Zach said go ahead
and get spoiled if you want head on over
there after this because this is where
the actual fun is uh Black Adam two
producers revealed a sequel plan release
date and timeline it's uh they said
Hiram Garcia here I'm Garcia Garcia hire
them Hiram Garcia are you right yes yeah
Dr Phil's always right it's not good I
know how to pronounce names like Hiram
Jacob
Jacob Samuel okay there you go they said
it's not going to take that long I can
promise you that we always hope the
first Domino's uh the easy one will get
cooking on it fast that's for sure
so that that feels like a non-answer
that feels like of course that's like uh
what's the producer equivalent of
thirsty thespians
producer right of course oh you think I
think that was pretty that was like
clearly like please give me a sequel
yeah oh definitely they're parched they
want to but I I mean I don't think it
there's no it's not like green letter
yeah I mean they're like if they want it
we'll get right on yes All Dwayne has to
do is go over the heads of everybody and
do it possible it's true who's gonna say
no to him I'm not gonna fight him that's
what he'll come down to uh Pierce
Brosnan reveals Doctor Strange inspired
him for the Dr Fate role which looks
like someone that watched a lot of
Doctor Strange movies and jumped into
this movie uh when asked why he chose
this role his main reason he said Doctor
Strange I love doctor strange and my
sons who are comic book aficionados
would say Dad Doctor Strange that's
that's it talk to him every morning say
Dad it's Christmas Christmas morning
don't you want to say that
Dr Strange Daddy yeah Doctor Strange I
haven't seen you in 13 years my boy my
boy my breakfast you were crawled out of
that well we threw you down well and he
goes I say well we all know Doctor
Strange is the interviewer did and he
especially is brilliant uh but and he is
especially brilliant Benedict but then
you have the bookend to that and it's Dr
Fate and Dr Fate is much loved one of
the senior members of The Sorcerer's
sorcerer's world uh does he know that
they're not in the same cinematic I
think I think he went to a comic book
store he's like I don't know one of
these doctor characters hey you nerd
what's like Doctor Strange what day is
it nerd it's Easter Sunday give me the
largest Doctor Strange Omnibus possible
I want to shout it out we will be
consuming some hot sauce thank you to
knick-knack Alma pal uh Francisco Sosa
you have an awesome name Uno uh and all
the other folks thrown in super
unpronounceable yeah starting us off big
today already yeah somebody crossed into
the first time we should think it's
Friday we should be thankful to some of
our trashiest trash bags thank you
Christian is a frequent contributor and
we appreciate from that from the great
right north of America
yes I'll get us through these headlines
quicker so we can just go on to chewing
up this horrible horrible songs take
your time please go slower
black Superman
the movie still moving forward you guys
it's still supposed to be going in
production it's in development right now
uh tanishi Coates I believe it's how
it's pronounced black Superman movie is
still slated to go into production for
Warner Brothers Discovery even after
reports noted that the company is moving
forward with a sequel to 2013's Man of
Steel do it good now I forgive my
ignorance on this uh everyone at the
table uh a black Superman is is not the
actual type no that's that's just
something we're throwing in like when
people were like it's black Annie and
I'm like I don't think you should say
that uh uh who are these people but it's
not he's not Clark Kent right it's a
different Superman because this is the
only reason I'm saying this
Steve Harvey make a hell of a Jonathan
okay Barbie would make a hell maybe a
drawer out maybe a jar out oh yes Steve
Harvey uh well and I think me you the
star of The Steve Harvey Show real
sincere moments in that show yeah this
whole thing is why they're so they need
to put out the splash movie despite what
the world wants uh I think because this
slash movie is probably setting up all
these universes and like separate
timelines and all the Multiverse systems
yeah what they what they've done in the
MCU they want to do in the DCU to kind
of so they could just have everything
Loosely connected so they gotta get this
Flash movie uh so that they can set all
that up yes and if folks don't know ton
of hissy coats is a super well expected
yeah uh comic writer who wrote a lot of
the uh recent black panther uh
storylines uh Ryan coogler has pulled
into the films he had some
um uh really popular runs on Captain
America and I think he did do maybe a
Superman
um we have a special guest that will
confirm that in a few
um uh yeah so uh and I think this is
also the film that Michael B Jordan was
attached to right or yeah I don't know
how attached he was yeah
emotionally very emotionally attached to
it yeah uh so before we get into our
discussion do we need to do our first we
do need to redeem okay we're gonna we're
gonna begin our hot sauce Journey oh and
speaking of special guests
how does it feel to be between Dr Phil
and Steve Harvey uh like a lawsuit okay
someone get this child again
Sean you make a living tortured people
with hot sauces how does that make you
feel
so in doing research on Dr Phil is your
doctorate in real medicine or conception
I'm actually a doctor in what they call
the sexual magic
the mustache is that to hide any birth
defect or abnormality or is that
something you've had since birth no this
is for the ladies
well you took over Legends of the Hidden
Temple did you imply that it was already
legendary do you feel the legend has
grown by this implication the temple is
actually in my backyard
lure the children to it like a fight now
as the man who kind of started the whole
reality TV gig do you find that it is
eroding our society as quickly or more
quickly than you expected to see people
be that awful on National Television I I
wish I could answer that question Sean
but I've been a Cambodian jungle too
long to understand uh basic human speech
damn Sean came in with these questions
all right what's the name of this sauce
all right so first we've got the uh
classic hot sauce is a chili Maple by
heatonist this is a very very small
amount of reasonable scovilles I do
believe this is a uh I used to do that
where are the scovilles at on here Sean
two out of ten heat meter okay we got
this everybody okay okay two out of ten
so wait is it we put more on we need to
put it on right yeah the Nugget is
already coated it's already coated oh
it's already coated it's pre-sauce the
production team here uh
this is for 50. we're very close to the
next hot sauce
is that what Steve Harvey does
um tasty not too bad it's nice crazy
easy it's enjoyable
um not even a problem yeah if you uh you
could create uh film juice shame on you
um I am Johnny snow everybody that's
throwing in uh Dublin to the Super Chat
yeah well Christian unpronounceable he's
sent out a Super Chat that was like I
know I keep harping on about it but I
still think they're gonna plant the
seeds of Aurora in wakanda forever now
we saw in the trailer uh we saw in the
trailer that like there was a lot of new
stuff so there was some two new kind of
like featurettes that came out last
night this is for what kind of friend
black panther what kind of forever and
they have like lots of new stuff in it
one of them kind of like Christian was
talking about we saw a little lightning
strike people were like oh Aurora you
know we want to see storms maybe I don't
know that would be a lot to get into I I
don't know we'll see we'll see but one
of the things that we noticed right away
in this trailer is that there's a little
clip of shuri and she's saying vibranium
he's covered in it right and they kind
of show that shot of them with the
Spears on the beach or whatever but it
sounds like the clip is like 80 yards
and we don't know if that's when she's
saying it necessarily but we kept
thinking like what is she talking about
like there's a lot of things to unpack
here in this one little sentence right
yes first of all vibranium he's covered
in it is that a literal thing or is that
like metaphorical like is someone in a
literal suit covered in vibranium or is
that like saying he's got a lot of
vibranium on like he's dripping with
jewels I also think it's interesting
because of the scene we saw at Comic-Con
we're in thanks Steve uh wherein we got
the moment where they were arguing about
keeping it to wakanda right what if
vibranium got out like they were worried
about and someone like a certain
Liberian dictator was able to perhaps
acquire the thing they were most I don't
think that's a coincidence those two
seems like yes you think it's Doom
I think we're all doomed yeah well we
were going to speculate on we were going
to speculate on because we don't see
this coming out of her mouth right in
that scene we don't know who she's
talking about like the the dialogue is
played over an image of Neymar right so
like yeah we were gonna say well first
off if it is Neymar and it may not be
and we'll talk about that in a second
but if it isn't anymore what could that
mean I was saying what if much like Phil
uh fish are covered
it's like Phil right here it's like Phil
and fish are covered in a thin layer of
slime that protects their scales it
keeps them impenetrable what if there is
some kind of like you know Neymar's from
the ocean there's some kind of like
microfilament kind of uh uh transparent
film of
um of the material that like allows him
to be you know basically impenetrable
himself almost like what we see in
Guardians of the Galaxy where they're in
space and they have those little like
honeycomb suit that can just kind of
appear over this vibranium yeah is there
like a liquid I mean we already know
that like the Black Panther suit is like
a nano mesh vibranium that is very
flexible and movable but yeah if there's
like a clear version that he's wearing
that we can't even see well she could
detect it what if the the Nano uh robots
that make up the uh Black Panther suit
what if there's like literal vibranium
Crustaceans that live on the ocean floor
that freaking expand out from his you
know chest plate or something like that
I think we need to talk about the
trailer itself right a little bit so
they are on like it's like a beach we
also have Angela Bassett we're seeing
her like hair she's not actually in any
of her like what we normally see her
head Garb as so it's like what is on
that it looks like a little it looks
like the same Beach that we see
um
um Baku jumping off of the ship onto the
island of but I also was like What if
it's that character that we see that's
right after the fight with
um the door milage she's all or they are
all blewed out all right
that beam talocan uh beings that are
like because there's a two what what
yeah namora and
yeah like the other ones down there like
the blue the blue ones what about
there's also I don't think anyone said
this yet what if they first uh assume
that ironheart is a guy and that is
iron-hearted we're gonna get to
everybody else
well sorry go ahead sorry I was just
gonna say yeah is it like is he is it
someone in a full suit of vibrant or is
it like metaphorical like they have so
much because vibrating is very precious
right and and wakandas have never seen
outside the Condon have lots of
vibranium right yes as far as we yeah no
that's why I agree with you with the it
coming out of the sea the sea floor and
it's just like growing because I'm like
I think these people are just swimming
right welcome back to hot ones now our
last sauce was 1600 Scoville units and
it was like a sweet refresh now this is
a much much more aggressive still not
too crazy we're talking four thousand
Scoville units it's got a floaty Scotch
Binet situation I've never heard some
Maple describe
sisters
makes more sense and it combines
tropical fruit with mangoes papayas and
banana
and these aren't pre-sauced right these
are pre-sauce I'm gonna go a little bit
more
Ramsay loved this chicken I'm gonna pop
this like a papa that I did last night
oh my gosh Steve please I double damn
every chicken
eggs these are tasty let's get a little
bit more kick to it sticks on the tongue
a little bit very nice one thing you
said though Zach about the sea creatures
being transformed we do know is that
like the meteorite that put the Vibram
in wakanda the heart-shaped herb was
made from the radiation from the
vibranium which changed the plant life
around the crash in the meteor site now
in the comics there's like vibranium and
wakanda there's vibranium and Antarctica
uh there's vibranium in some little
little islands off the coast of Africa
but that's pretty much it and then some
people make synthetic vibranium right
well we have some vibranium down at the
ranch he's trying to make a coherent
point
oh so sorry if this is a situation where
like the the meteorite which struck and
put the Vibram in there we saw the like
the mining up operation goes deep deep
deep into the Earth this could be a
situation where there's a vein of
vibranium that is like going into the
ocean floor where the other end hits
talocon or wherever that's what I really
Colin have uh likewise with the
vibranium what if they have a
heart-shaped herb Under the Sea like
what because the vibranium is a
different kind heart shoulders help yes
yeah show me heart-shaped pills
help but I think you know the
you know that a heart-shaped herb was
the vibranium like parallel right like
that was a key part of what the
meteorite did what if there's an equal
version of that for the Atlantean yeah
well the the thing I like about that is
everything the thing I don't like about
that is a lot of it so what if I I like
the idea of them making their own kind
of herb but do you think it's just
inferior to theirs that's why they're
coming up from above the water it's a
kidney shift curve
we see name orbs basically flying right
right so it's like damn black panther
can't do that but the rest of them are
flying well I guess it's one person
taking it and then he's half Atlantic
and half him what if that unique biology
makes him able to fly well and Neymar's
mutant ability is flight as far as we
know right those wings aren't they never
really like established and breathing
underwater and maybe smoke that's the
atlantian or Tallow portion of him yeah
I also this might not come um at all
squeeze skull
um I don't think this will come to
fruition in the movie but I recite this
like memory what Brandon told me on big
question once about how Bass the got the
Egyptian God one of the Indian was the
one that brought the heart-shaped her to
wakanda so I like the idea of like if
we're still going off that theory from
the comic books would that Encompass the
kind of work wouldn't it right would
that also that be insane that'd be so
insane if I do a lot of narrative but
it's a 300 you can tell all that yeah
that story of like bass bearing the
heart to protect it that's like real
mythology that's in our that's a real
that's real mythology Egyptian mythology
but we've also already met Moss right
yeah Thor and Thor and and we've had
we've talked about this a lot in this
show I love that all the gods seem to be
coming through and especially if that
rumor of Mephisto is a thing what if
there's another element of gods and
afterlife like we've already had in some
of the other shows also they will just
have to learn to like coexist under that
God yeah because black panther is the
avatar for boss and then cuckoo con is
the avatar for Google gone right Neymar
is the Avatar in a way for cuckoo yes
well we do know there has been some
theories that like wakanda's running out
of vibranium which to me sounds insane
considering how much we saw the mining
out of the Earth but if that's true and
they're in the process of looking for it
that's how they find run into like name
more and stuff because they also
established
they all have established that there's
uh the wakandas are not aware of anymore
yeah this is all a surprise
uh this is 15 500 Scoville so we left
from 1600 to 4 000 now this is a leap
from four thousand to fifteen thousand
five hundred now this is a new one to
the hot ones family a Pico pepper bring
fresh flavor to the three spot out of
Montreal Canada and Pico Rico this
features Savory and acidic notes of
tomato and lemon juice with just the
right habanero heat and let me tell you
let me tell you I know a lot about
slavery
okay thank you to Aaron storm
ready townsman and AJ ajb coming through
with the big the big Bank thank you for
that and this is a Canadian hot sauce
Christian unpronounceable our other
friends north of the Border uh bless you
for your efforts here let me tell you I
can tell just from the smells yeah ready
has a birthday tomorrow Happy Birthday
let me tell you what Steve thinks of
that or my favorite yeah so let's so
let's talk about who these candidates
could be if she's not talking about
she's talking about somebody else yeah
it could be any more yes I have this
theory that maybe I think a Tuma might
be that's spicy
that's like too much of my turn actually
a tumor might turn out to be like our
third act villain in the way that like
atuma pushes a war that maybe Neymar
doesn't want but now Neymar is forced to
back like his people it's a bit like
Daniel kaluya's character I forget that
uh character's name but uh from Black
Panther one right like kind of like a
person who switches sides a little bit
against our hero yeah oh we have to go
immediately so we are going immediately
into the next tier up we are now into
the Calientes Barbacoa hey this is 33
000 Scoville this is a smoldering
background lineup is the Los Calientes
Barbacoa it is the smokiest sauce of the
season it's got Maplewood smoked red
jalapeno and dried chipotle peppers and
that is what gives the rose gold
Barbacoa it's flame kissed flavor oh I'm
starting to feel it on Steve's big old
lips
you all don't have to give this
generously anymore we forgot we've seen
it generation trash bag this is me GSU
eagle117 uh saying Zach with the shame
shorts on Ice are you wearing your
flashcard oh you're wearing shorts today
wait what makes them shame uh yesterday
on the show we discussed tonight called
his uh his name or outfit is James
shorts because he had to walk around in
them he refused to wear it can I have a
little bit four out of 10. oh okay I ate
myself
that's a real nice flavor I've never had
something to blow my back out
clean RT music thank you
um Dr Phil's never been more High I
don't know if that's a reference to the
hot sauces or just your naked sexuality
uh well what can I say uh I think one I
am starting to sweat under this headband
and two as a man gets older he releases
pheromones that is undeniable to the
fairer sex and to his own sex and he
becomes desirable to all Sexes he
becomes omnisexual
and that's why I'm releasing Dr Phil's
omnisexual hexagonal chapsticks and
prophylactics all right it'd be nice if
you guys stop giving us money
next one is a Sichuan no I can't just
look transparently it looks like
something that goes into a car yeah
that's like what's going to be coming
out of me later yeah we're all about to
change our fluids I don't have insurance
so for those of us that don't have
health insurance do we have to finish
the [ __ ] it's called it says not
traditional but personally which I
appreciate I like that it's a threat
it's a little bit of a threat so a tumas
one option right yes it could also be
like a military group that they stumble
upon we do know that like countries
militaries are trying to get in there to
steal a little vibranium yes we've also
seen He was discussing the Betrayal with
uh Daniel glue as camera but we also
have seen now that mbaku is with them
and I think there's a reason that umbaku
changed his tune a bit from like we are
now we are a different tribe this is and
at the end we started to see that like
you know camaraderie but what if there's
an outside force that forces the
wakandans to all bond together yeah
which would be the interesting thing if
they kind of reveal that there is
vibranium available to talocon then it's
like what if telecon's like well
we just are now realizing there's
competition for
um you know we want to be the
monopolists in the vibranium game or
whatever yeah well I like that
somebody's saying what if they're uh is
somebody else in a vibranium suit yeah
we know Riri Williams is going to be in
this now it could be her or maybe that's
why she needs to suit up to fight
against an antagonist that's in a
similar kind of how to have like a very
fancy suit by the end of this we saw in
this teaser a pretty fancy full-on like
Mach 5 and that's right it's got a lot
of people my ears are starting to sweat
now of course it could be like Doom in a
full metal outfit like really uh cover
with vibranium I think his his suit is
not traditionally vibranium I believe no
no it's actually made by Tibetan Monks
in the comic books it's just a metal
suit Doom 616 his suit is made with help
of Tibetan Monks uh I just read that
yesterday Dr Phil coming into
one thing I do love about Zoom suits in
the comic books we found this out the
other day uh trying to discover uh Jesus
Christ's Canon within the MCU he is of
course yeah uh so Doom suit has pieces
of the True Cross inside of it like what
splinters just in case it runs across
Dracula that's how well prepared Doom is
he's like just in case of everything
he's in that area near Transylvania
right like just in case I run into
Dracula I got a little bit well if he's
dealing with magic and science would
make sense to prepare for the occult and
anything else around it's true I like
that I respect I like this going back to
like a vibranium he's covered in it
right uh we we mentioned right like the
Black Panther suits are made from
vibranium uh but the way she's saying
that is not like hey that's a friend
right that somebody who a combatant an
enemy something like that what is
somebody else going to get a hold we
know somebody who's not your child is
wearing a black panther suit in this
movie uh the first black panther
obviously killmonger got a suit on is
some other bad guy getting a hold of a
black panther I was gonna say is there
is there a false black panther that
they're like someone's impersonating the
Black Panther like a Black Flag Panther
yes yes you know how there used to be a
false flag that's what you're saying now
I are you sir I'm a little slow on the
uptake on the counter uh the fact that I
bathe in liquid gold you
get comic book
anytime you wear a mask you expose
yourself to imposters that's why I
always advise my kids to go to my Ranch
take the mask off take the mask off and
show your real beautiful face then
you're one of a kind like a diamond or a
snowflake the the chameleon that's why
everyone hates Spider-Man in New York
because it's one of his first villains
he dressed up as Spider-Man rob the bank
thanks uh to the uh awful work of ajb
Brianna Johnson Quinton Tyler Nev Harris
uh we were about to take a journey uh in
the transparent territory house hey hey
folks I'm I'm feel pretty uncomfortable
right now if you can slow those chats
down just a bit I'm sure some of y'all
got dumpsters you gotta sweep out this
weekend we only have two weeks we are
about to fly by Jing through this
Sichuan gold 46 000 Scoville Delight
forty six thousand so this is crafted in
Chengdu the heart of China Sichuan
Province the Sichuan gold brings all the
addicting Umami notes of chili crisp
without the crisp this oil-based sauce
is one of a kind flavor lights up the
number five Wing we're five deep into
Sichuan we're halfway there
yeah
I happen to know a little bit about this
because I'm a big fan of Chinese food I
got you Chengdu is the capital of the
Sichuan regime in which is a northern
internal region in China known for its
Chile it's peppercorns uh that have a
unique numbing effect on the tongue
almost a novocaine kind of thing you say
they got peppercorns
it tickles the back oh yeah this one
layers it lingers
that's an interesting Journey okay it
went down there it's just so immediately
aggressive
a big question in this movie of course
is like who's wearing a suit uh we've
been thinking maybe there's multiple
people in suits they're kind of making
it clear that shuri is definitely in the
suit we've been seeing yeah uh we see
the her famous kind of Panther cannons
on the fists it seems to be like a
slight feminine body on the poster she's
front and center mirrored with uh Namor
underneath as like these are the two
opposing forces no and they're behind
one of them
we'll have to wait till John's back but
like they even they put out these like
character posters yesterday as well
which feature like uh uh several of the
characters in their like armor and sure
he's not an armor like a coyison armor
uh uh Romanticism like an armor
um
but she's just wearing like a regular
suit so it's like it's kind of like
they're saying hey sure is clearly in
this suit this is the turmeric bomb
which is 69 000. nice Scoville nice this
is hot one's favorite Honduran hot sauce
and this is turmeric bomb highlights
Tangy turmeric zappy Ginger Scotch
bonnet chocolate ghost and jalapeno
peppers as well as an authentic Honduran
Spirit
aguadante
Brandon accidentally went really heavy
on his head off Dr filthy looks like
he's getting this shout out to our
viewers in uh Honduras
shout out to our Honduran visitors mmm
Christy Coy had or koi Chrissy had a
question for you yes as someone who was
raised outside of Boston Massachusetts
you don't seem to have an accent anymore
how long do you think it took Settlers
of the USA to lose their British accent
Jesus well my trick was I watched uh
YouTube videos of dialects from like
totally different like sections of the
country to find a neutral so I actually
like spent six months trying to lose
mine because I sounded like an Affleck
well and uh Chrissy a little a
historical fun fact
um we didn't lose our British accents
the British accent changed oh yeah uh uh
we people in England around the time of
uh you know coming to the New World had
American accents and then over time the
English accent changed we didn't want to
sound like us dumb Americans yeah
[Applause]
in 1600 was going hey I'll take a
meatball sandwich uh my name's Oliver
they think they think that traditionally
the Brits sounded more like how they
sound in South Carolina now which is a
very old and that the Victorian English
came around like in Shakespeare's time
they didn't sound like oh Shakespeare
Star Trek 2024 wants us to suffer I
don't even know John get that next
Nuggie I don't even know what currency
that is is that oh is that wakandan I
feel like I'm being bad that is a unique
uh StarTek where are you from
um yeah we're we're our next one of my
tongue feels like a goddang volcano and
the only solution
is for me to go jump in the closest body
of water which I believe is the LA River
which sounds very infrequently has any
water that's not tainted with human
blood I feel like I'm seeing things
Brandon and I have both kayaked on the
LA River
um but you shouldn't drink the water our
next one is the cosmic disco uh funkin
hot sauce
um and again we're getting down here
Into the Danger Zone 103 000 Scoville
the worst that any of us have ever had a
few people have done the the bomb and
claimed that it ruined their lives so we
are one away from that I don't want to
do that well why why
sorry Dr Bell one other thing uh
yeah oh God I'm sweating it go go
one other thing that uh we should bring
up is like producer named more I said
like quote like this black panther has
existed in what kind of for centuries
so the notion of someone else picking up
the mantle didn't seem inorganic all of
the characters in the film have a
different idea of who should done the
mantle and why oh I like that
perspective so we know that it seems
like they're they're very much tipping
to have that sure will be on it but
we're also thinking like other people
and she may not end the film right and
that's so interesting all of the
characters have a different idea of who
should Don the mantle and why it's like
Ramona and shuri probably have different
ideas right well it's some we have a new
character in this film Anika who is
pretty recent to the comic she was first
created in like a 2009 and she's part of
a group called like the midnight Angels
yeah an offshoot of the Dora Milan yes
and like the the in those character one
shots okay is kind of wearing a very
like turquoise looking armor which is
uh and it kind of looks like the
midnight angels and we also see Nikia
walking with the group in an armor that
could also be the midnight angels and
like that whole storyline will put
t'challa sends the midnight Angels after
Doom because he's stolen all the
vibranium and wakanda is this flood a
cover to steal vibrating or something
like that and that's how we get into
like this whole because Neymar's also
said that he's not the enemy which is
interesting with all this geopolitical
Intrigue we've got multiple perspectives
and we've also seen that there is uh
elements in the comics right now of
t'challa like reaching out to other
nations and planting spies and right now
he's not the king of wakanda because he
feels betrayed so that might tie into
what they're doing with the these
daughters and like that storyline so all
of this could work and they've said time
and time again they do story lines about
10 years out and then they plant seeds
to see what sells 2009 like they could
have seen that go well and now they can
be part well and one thing we've been
talking about is like we've seen a lot
now there's been like the total footage
that's been released in this film and
all the trailers is pretty is pretty
significant but they obviously are not
showing us a lot as well and like one
thing we haven't seen in all the footage
of Neymar we've seen him like go up to
the glass and the wakandan tower like
he's gonna break the glass he's flying
around he's like uh some somebody's like
breaking a stick over his back he's not
even flinching we have not seen him
perpetuate violence on
I'm suspect of that shot of him as the
reflection because they're looking
they're not really reacting could it be
like a dream sequence or something like
that or like it's not him and they're
hiding what is actually there in that
shot we know they love to play around
with like not putting in assets they
don't need to and I you know why put
that show on the trailer if you're
trying to figure this out I don't know
but if they want us to think that
Neymar's a bad guy but they're gonna
actually have it be someone else and
that group that Nakia is a part of yeah
sorry the wedding the midnight Midnight
Angels they are in the comics are often
portrayed as having the ability to fly
they have like
them to to fly too so like could that be
that's actually her it would be
interesting if like Queen raimonda and
shuri are like we want to take the
country this way and Nikki is like no
like I don't think that's the right way
to go and forms a little group of door
milage who don't agree and like yeah
they have like their own little Civil
War within the country and Neymar's like
you guys can't be doing this yes there's
other out there and while the country is
weak and they've already said that a lot
of the voice over the trailer is talking
about like t'challa talk about taking
over wakanda I don't feel like it's that
on the nose but it could be you know
that situation Jesus
who's Jesus Jesus is Canada I guess yeah
Jesus GSU Eagles saying we need Phil to
feel the burn from his fill hole down to
his film hole Bam from a Dr Phil to my
naughty spill oh boy oh my gosh is
anyone else's fingertips completely numb
right now
to not drink water because of the cap
station stuff we have milk I will not
drink we do have milk at least half the
cast is uh uh allergic to milk as Sean
Evans I don't touch water I survived
this whole thing as is now a friendly
reminder to watch your eyes don't touch
near eyes of those fingers you gotta be
careful I'll say one thing Sean Evans is
is having a hard time right now I hear
you next to me because I don't drink
water
I can't move my arms above my head
medically if my arms your left arm Dr
Phil no make sure it's not hard you're
not having a heart attack why does Sean
Evans wear layers it's so hot have you
ever noticed that he's always got layers
on
Stephanie Horton GSU Eagle Jamir green
Al rinconace uh thank you all I think
we're about to really enter the the pain
Dome here
um to wrap this all up just kind of
forever
[Music]
it seems like sure is going to be in a
black panther suit do you think she is
gonna be the Black Panther at the end of
this movie or it'll go a different
direction I think the reason they're
hiding it is because the average person
doesn't know it but I don't know if that
means that it isn't How It Ends right
like I could easily see the average
person doesn't know the comic books like
we're in a very specific bubble right I
can see a lot of people being surprised
by shuri that that being said it does
that end that way
yeah
hey yo I'm actually pretty that's what
we call Cracker play uh it's pretty
popular uh it was down in my region in
Texas this is when you get a cracker to
feed a cracker uh somebody I think I was
squared because received as a result of
some crackers I was gonna say cracker
plays when uh uh Dr Phil's family puts
on a uh production of Oklahoma
this spicy mix of red jalapenos and
scorpion peppers is Celestial mashup of
two of Karma's most popular sauces
Cosmic dumpling and Scorpion Disco This
is a Savory soy Citrus notes they
collided the bright Chili Bomb for some
out of this world grew I'm about to
enter the cosmic disco I think real
quick before uh we lose our faculties
yeah oh my god oh yeah yeah go ahead so
we do want to remind you guys that Pluto
tv offers hundreds of free live channels
thousands of free on-demand movies watch
them while you eat maybe then also it's
it's Friday yeah um now while our faces
are turning unnatural Shades as we
consume these weird chemicals
brought to you by our good friends at
geology uh our fresh face this week you
know what he's not the freshest face to
the broader world but to the MCU he is
Sasha Baron Cohen uh there he is look at
that nice mug nothing's hotter than that
but these wings oh my God I'm still
trying to stay with my bit but I can't
oh oh oh oh he's about to throw up don't
do it though
um
rumored to be joining the MCU as uh
devilish demon um Mephisto we're excited
for that
um of course
uh Bruno and Borat and Les Mis and
brothers Grims Hugo of course you know
him from Brothers Grimsby people don't
like the brothers Grimsby everybody saw
him and Mark Strong as uh
all right what about the house oh God I
actually have a cameo in the brothers
Grimsby
not a lot of people know that is that
true yeah I'm Scared movie before dude
came over here with two handfuls of
bread and a whole bunch of crackers I
was like oh great he's bringing them for
the table
um for him and a little bit
we want to shout out Sasha Barrett I
have to stand it's getting too hot to
sit
um
uh but uh much like Sasha Baron joining
the MCU you should join uh the club and
get yourself some geology skincare we
have a whole range of products to help
your skin look its best they'll even
help you find the products best suited
to your needs take it take the quiz at
geology.com
they'll suggest the perfect lineup of
skincare items for you they also have
this great new uh hair care and shampoo
lines they're really excited about we've
been trying out here
head to geology.com new rockstars and
use our promo code rockstar70 to save 70
off 70 off uh when you use Rockstar 70
that's about the percent off that all of
us feel from our normal homeostasis
right now after eating all that my
eyeballs hurt you should put some wing
sauce in it I feel totally fine it's
time for mandatory fun
what's more fun than this I'll be honest
with you I thought this was gonna be way
hotter look at my mustache coming down
I'll teeter totter
hey you've made it to refund the
segment's so hot we play the graphic a
lot hit it again
yes it's time for mandatory fun hosted
by Dr Phil so we play the graphic more
than Neil into the game
yes it's time for mandatory fun the
graphic where you have control of your
life so hit the graphic with no Strife
hit it again you have control
yes time for mandatory fun but we've
been eating a lot of hot nuggets so [ __ ]
it hit the ground again
yes it's mandatory fun the segment where
we all like to laugh and have a good
time so hit the graphic maybe even nine
yeah
Steve I mean
it's like looking in a mirror
all right now it's game show day what
happens now so we decided to let Jessica
Clement start a feud
oh Phoenix God damn you Phoenix TV
ready ready
okay we're doing the bomb I'll be
standing for this portion once you got
scared with my big old jacket uh oh God
I really don't want to do this I really
don't I have children I have children in
a home to get to as we wait for these
other rings to come out we got we got
two teams now you guys know how Family
Feud works yeah we know how it works you
all know how Family Feud works oh my god
do you guys want team names you guys
want to call left and right table where
the where the bottle stands okay we're
we're Cosmic disco yeah the cosmic disto
and the butter stands
just uh broke out of prison to steal a
baby
oh this is
layer of vibranium Tommy yes so I shake
hands real quick you guys know how the
game oh they're gonna scream all right
I'm gonna go with what whoever answers
first oh my God all right everybody this
is the bomb this is the bomb everybody
knows all about the bomb but just in
case you don't it is 135 600 Scoville
now you might be asking yourself where's
the usual the bomb well here at Heaton
this we only carry non-extract sauces we
created this all natural addition that's
powerful and tastes good because food
tastes good so this is all natural no
chemicals oh wow
there's nothing natural about what's
about to happen every time
every oh I'm feeling it I'll give it a
little bit oh it's in the back of my
throat
team the last one yeah
oh wow like peppering oh my God was
there another mug here I'm chipping my
gums it's not that bad oh this one's
right here this one's awful what are you
talking about I know this one's the
worst the gums are so bad I need some of
that milk listen a lot of people know
I'm a classically trained actor none of
this has bothered me I'm totally fine
this is the first one that's really
getting to me oh I'll be honest I could
do the rest of the sauces
milk John milk me
this feels broken like my pores great
question should my butthole be tingling
it's like a slow pucker Unleashed
the sweet nectares my ass almost like
the Starlight pit okay Steve do this
okay Boba Fett's coming
[Laughter]
first don't donate another dollar
six hands top six answers on the board
you guys first one to answer the high
oh
God
in my next life I'd want to be Steve
Harvey's Blake yeah penis
let butt cheek left butt cheek
damn give me another
bank account
prenup
Sun
you know a legitimate daughter I'll give
it to you
are you guys going to play you guys
gonna go where's your pass we should
pass we should pass you're passing
that's twenty dollars what is this
category
oh
in another life I'd want to be Steve
Harvey's blank go ahead you guys team
what you guys come up with the sun sun
what do you think son you guys going
with style child kid
[Music]
yeah also you guys I got all these
answers from everybody in the office I
did a poll of every single person in the
office okay keep going mustache it's
their turn
like a dog pet
pet
I love her no wife husband is already
11. you guys still got it
I'm gonna get bread I'm gonna be Steve
Harvey's not mustache we already said
must have no Chloe said mustache
um mustache mustache
on the board I got the top answer is you
have to be answered right go ahead go
ahead keep going do they have one strike
or two strikes agent that one agent
agent
you got one more uh and then they got a
chance to steal uh suit
wardrobe wardrobe wardrobe yeah
oh [ __ ]
same difference same difference keep
going you can keep going oh God these
are common answers from everybody in our
office that we got them from everybody
friend and the next life you want to be
Steve Harvey's blank yeah best friend
friendship's important
you guys got a chance to steal the last
two
well you can't steal the last one I'm
sorry I'm really hot
also let it be known both members of
this team took extra hot sauce
now that should that should be a
detriment the highest one oh God that
was terrible yeah
go ahead you guys you guys gotta choose
come on time's up time's up you guys
still have the worst answer and the top
answer that we got in our office we'll
go with accountant
for seven points you could have got a
car
and the top answer in our office at new
rock stars his killer first kill
one more game
who has the most points Dr Phil is
peeling like an onion over there we'll
take it over here because they're having
a hard time
okay yeah it's me and Brandon Brandon
ready oh God yeah I'm gonna go through
this gambling the whole milk
somebody's doing the omad challenge over
here name something a bald guy wouldn't
want to find on his head bro a bird [ __ ]
bird [ __ ] yeah uh I'm gonna say on his
head
um
uh skin cancer perfect
you want to play this one I think so
we'll play it we'll play we'll play okay
keep going baby keep going baby yeah
ball guy doesn't want to find on his
head a ball guy doesn't want to find on
his head he said it he said tomb right
okay
remember this is what people knew rock
stars said
uh food
food food
foreign
[Music]
his agent his accountant you guys got
the chip head well my partner I think is
is oh my God Dr filthy might be dead oh
okay
he's never been more alive
a pair of jeans running around name
something a ball guy doesn't want to
find on his head uh another smaller bald
guy no hang on that's not I realized
okay now they said stuff like uh um [ __ ]
I've already forgotten what they said my
brain is so hot
uh a toupee yeah
bad wig a bad wig
that's a steal that's the steal you guys
missed
drugs say it with me now
I was right last but not least
[Music]
I asked I asked the office what's the
thing that you eat on a side of hot
wings
of going to a really dark place we're in
a dark place we're all standing my heart
is beating too fast
we're layers
[Applause]
this is just our weird way of showing it
I mean what a what a weird relationship
we have with you guys uh Ryan house kid
saying you are the bomb yeah we both
consumed a bomb and we are to bum every
time John comes and drops these off he
seductively touches my backs and I love
it what was uh okay so this one is this
is a unique garlic this is a smoking oh
this is a pepper butt pepper coat by the
way unique garlic pepper smoking Ed
Curie is back in the nine spot super
Savory garlic mixes with super hot
chilies like Ed's famous Carolina Reaper
Scorpion and seven hot Primo Peppers
this power of garlic combined with the
heat can do some serious damage and not
just the vampires maggots Michael I like
uh you said things I didn't hear that
saying in the chat we should run a poll
on who's gonna poop their pants first
well uh if there's a bowl I already won
you may not notice crap doctor filthy's
in a new pair of pants it's been a
blowout folks here we go last dab oh
thank you congrats everyone oh that
one's not bad that one's actually good
let me finish mine
tremendous flavor holy crap oh that's so
good that was that was 642 000 Scoville
oh it's building slowly it is building I
like that one pepper butt pepper butt oh
it's it's still building over half a
million Scoville
still building oh yeah oh each each
second is a little worse than the I
genuinely like that one so I don't I'm
not feeling the same thing
do you have the vapors do you have them
I do have the vapors I think hold on all
right what's everybody's weekend plans
with my best friends I'm gonna go to the
doctor and make sure um tickets
this one's like in my cheeks somehow
it's like uh slowly Rising I'm not even
kidding I was gonna go see don't worry
darling but I'm very worried darling
uh let it hit my uvula
oh my God
milk I'm sorry
well thank you to our super challenge
today for being so awesome there is
sharing milk like this from from our
word spitters to our pants [ __ ] okay
we appreciate you guys you know what the
good news is if I can uh I'm gonna be
going live live tweeting uh the first
two episodes of peripheral right after
this on Twitter from the new rockstars
account so you can imagine how
distressed I'm gonna be yeah the other
thing is we didn't make it through all
10 which means we're gonna have to do
this again again there's ten this is
nine to nine oh we almost made it to ten
we didn't do we did the last dab we
didn't do the last step
uh check out Black Adam this weekend if
you feel like it we'll have a breakdown
up on the channel bottles my feet are
sweating make sure to watch uh the house
of the Dragon finale join us on talking
dragons on money that's got to discuss
that finale uh apologies for Andor
apologies to Anton we will be resolving
our She-Hulk fantasy next week
hanging the champion on the walk giving
them their prize
fantasy next week as well make sure to
like the video if you haven't already
I'm sure you like the pain you put us in
uh and don't forget Pluto TV has uh
hundreds of free channels and thousands
of free movies on demand check them out
uh they've been a great sponsor of the
show this week uh and we thank you all
for joining us also real quick if any of
you have another idea that's similar to
hot ones but different but you would
love to see us partake a challenge or
something like that maybe like delicious
gummy candies yeah something like that
some ice cream and one last thing you
can send a rooster loose in a hand house
but you can't make them screw all right
have a great weekend keep your dreams in
the clouds and your nightmares in your
sheets I love you all very much there's
your camera there's a camera there's a
camera the red carpets rolled out tell
the people what you're doing right
[Laughter]
[Music]
no nine was way less than 80
.
[Music]